[Music]
the 2008 financial collapse was huge in
complex it's causes or many bad risk
models bad government policies for sure
bad business decisions probably other
things too but while speaking on a panel
of feminists yesterday
Senate nonentity Kirsten Gillibrand of
New York identified another cause she
probably hadn't even thought of gender
men are the problem she said here's what
Jill Brennan said about the collapse of
the investment bank Lehman Brothers
watch that's why the empowerment of
women is so important throughout the
economy and through leadership through
these offices because we don't value
women in society and that's just the
fact you know if it wasn't leaving
brothers but Lehman sisters we might not
have had the financial collapse
[Applause]
Tammy Bruce is a radio host and
president of independents woman's voice
and she joins us tonight Amy I feel most
meeting playing that I you know I'm not
I don't dislike kirsten gillibrand I
felt sorry for watching that because it
was didn't make any sense it was kind of
sad but I thought maybe there's
something deeper here and since you're
our resident deep person I thought I'd
run it by you what do you think of that
well you know I can get as deep as just
saying that it was stupid it's insulting
yeah it is sexist and it's the argument
that misogynists make what she was
referring to is a study that said
because women are risk averse that they
would have taken less chances and so
Lehman Brothers would have been just
fine
this argument though puts all women into
a category of expecting their behavior
to be based on their gender and it is a
gender stereotypical it is based in a
sexist expectation that women are going
to behave a certain way because of their
sex and that and this is the other
argument that misogynist use is that
women are a risk averse and they're as a
result more frightened by things they're
less apt to take risks and you know
risks does not mean that you're that
it's a dumb decision look women's lives
are filled with risks when we wake up in
the morning it's risky we get pregnant
it's risky we give birth to children
it's risky we've changed the the Academy
we've changed the military everything we
do every day is a risk and we do it well
but the arguments by massage
sar that by pinning all women together
through their gender is that it's why
women don't make history it's that women
are not brave enough to do great art
that we aren't interesting enough to
invent things that we are not too brave
enough to be military leaders she's
arguing there through this risk-averse
gender-based stereotype that a woman
could also not be a president because
it's the same framework and this is what
we have to reject and and so of course
it's insulting and it is it is
misogynist and sexist to boot so I guess
I'm looking at it from the other angle
which is why is she attacking men hey
you know to me like I'm a man I have a
son who's an adult man he didn't do
anything to tank the banks you know what
I mean he would you talk about it all
the time from credit default swaps why
are you blaming a huge group for the
sins of a few because it's what you've
recognized repeatedly and I think
exclusively is this argument by the left
about toxic masculinity it is about it
is about condemning and in dying all men
for simply being men and her argument in
order to counter that you can't argue
what feminists have always at least my
generation did that women can do what
men do we in fact are very similar our
Styles might be more different but women
can accomplish what men accomplish what
she's arguing is since there's toxic
masculinity and that is a foundational
theory now of the left we have to
counteract it by saying that that the
peaceful simple woman who is not as
aggressive is the answer so this now
condemns them into putting women to one
category in order to succeed at
condemning all men and what they end up
doing is saying that women can't be
President women can't be a leader women
about by their will look we had one
president who behaved this way and it
was Barack Obama a man who was too
afraid to confront Isis too afraid of
his own redline with Syria too afraid to
really govern and help the economy too
afraid no one's around the world that's
what she's advocating for and it
certainly is not a feminine trait well I
don't blame all women for kirsten
gillibrand
Thank You Simon Debbie thank you it's
great to talk to you too my pleasure
thank you